goodbye Henry Cavill and hello second
most famous Hemsworth Brother The
Witcher season 3 part 2 has arrived with
all the daughter marrying sword breaking
action we've come to expect in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
part two its connection to the books
without spoilers and stay tuned till the
end of the video to see how the writers
are going to transition from Cavill to
Hemsworth I've left timestamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering The Season's final episode is
called the cost of chaos and the word
chaos here has a double meaning in the
world of The Witcher chaos is the source
of which magic is harnessed and it's
chaos that has now overtaken the
continent after the events of the thaned
coup at the end of part 1 We saw ahead
of rodanian intelligence sigismund
dixtra hold geralt at knife Point as the
Brotherhood conclave descended in an
all-out power grab between two rival
parties essentially you have vilgaforts
and the supporters of nilfgaard
including the scoia tell led by
Francesca versus sigismund in the
northern kingdoms with the Mages
choosing diff different sides themselves
but perhaps the biggest betrayal comes
from vilgafort's himself who turns
against his lover to sire revealing she
was merely a pawn in his Grand plans I
have my own aims and they no longer
include you I don't want to play with
you anymore this betrayal ends with her
nearly killing herself by using alzur's
Thunder and extremely powerful and
difficult spell to defend eritusa from
its Invaders although she survives the
coup the herd of her Lover's betrayal
heartbreak failure to protect the
Brotherhood and her own guilt leads her
to suicide in a letter to yennefer she
states that the use of chaos always
comes with a price and for what she did
she must pay there is a cost I must pay
the thaned coup also sees geralt face
off against the sorcerer vilgaforce who
up until this point has been hiding the
extent of his power now with the hardest
part was
holding
although he gives geralt one last chance
to join nilfgaard geralt denies him
leading to an absolutely brutal fight
scene that sees geralt get decimated in
fact vilgafort's staff is so powerful
that it shatters geralt's sword but
oddly enough vilgafort's lets geralt
live both to teach him a lesson and as a
warning to others this is where we begin
the final episode with geralt recovering
in Brooklyn Forest under the watchful
eye of the dryad queen ethnay its here
will also be introduced to milva one of
the few non-dryads tolerated in
Brooklawn and who will eventually join
geralt on his journey the Waters of
brokelon are said to possess a magical
healing properties but they are not
successful on geralt as the waters are
only meant for natural beings and he's
considered a mutant Jennifer will later
arrive and use magic to speed up the
healing process something that does not
happen in the book along with geralt is
yaskir who had his heart broken by
Prince radovid who is using him to get
to Siri even though he says his feelings
for The Bard were true radovid will
eventually become king of rodinia after
the sudden assassination of his elder
brother King vizimir putting his plans
to prove to yaskir that his feelings for
him are true on hold in the books
radovid is actually vizimir's son but
they've changed it to brother in the
show vizimir was assassinated by a
character named Eva who we had seen
intimate with Philippa elhart this
assassination was entirely orchestrated
by Philippa to install a new easier to
control King but it also had the added
benefit of saving dixtra who was gonna
kill himself as payment for him in
philippa's Failure at thaned the thaned
coup also saw Siri Escape of both
vilgaforts reince and kahir's clutches
kahir you may remember as the nif
guardian soldier who kidnapped Siri way
back in season 1 but has since learned
the error of his ways I've discovered I
was wrong he offers his life to her but
after he spared vows to find her and
proceed seeds to defend her against a
band of encroaching scoyatel then
there's reince who's made quick work of
by geralt in the book reince ends up
pursuing Siri and drowning in a frozen
lake where Siri runs over his fingers
with ice skates his fingers being cut
off by Siri in the show is a nod to this
and I can't help but wonder if yennefer
teaching Siri how to skate in part 1 was
a setup for this but due to time and
budget reince's death had to be
Rewritten finally there's vilgafort who
before pursuing Siri retrieves the book
of monoliths a book that may hold the
key to traveling Between Worlds you may
recall these monoliths are the tall
black stone-like structures found
throughout the continent we saw how
Siri's power can topple these monoliths
revealing portals to other Realms so
it's no surprise if vilgaforce would
want to control the girl with this
unique ability at the same time
vilgafort's teleports istrith through a
black portal telling him see you soon he
could have killed istrid but considering
he spared his life suggest he has other
plans after Garrett's decisive loss to
vilgafor it's been vilgofort's pursues
Siri into the Tower of Tor Laura in the
books the tower is home to benevan's
portal a portal which due to damage had
become unstable leading its users to
unexpected places many Mages perish
seeing where it led thus its use was
forbidden you'll notice it doesn't look
like a portal rather a giant monolith
similar to the smaller ones we've seen
before we also know Siri has the ability
to smash these monoliths creating
portals which seems to be the case here
but before she unlocks its power
vilgafort's entices Siri to become his
pupil and together they could change the
continent and change is definitely
something Siri wants I think I have
but change with that power hungry Mage
whose intentions aren't necessarily
clear or probably not her connection
with the portal is so strong it
essentially causes the entire Tower to
implode teleporting her to the Korat
desert a desert located to the east of
nilfgaard vilgafort's status isn't known
until the final episode where we can see
he sustained serious injuries to his
face including the loss of an eye at the
same time the Emperor of nilfgaard has
declared that he has found Siri and she
is to take her rightful place on the
throne this is an imposter known in the
books as cirilla Fiona or false Siri the
show doesn't tell us if the emperor
knows of this deception but given it was
vilgafort's who brought forth this girl
and that he likely thinks Siri was
killed in that explosion at Torah Lara
I'm inclined to believe the emperor
really thinks this is his daughter which
would be a departure from the book you
may also remember this false Siri as
Taran the girl geralt saved from volpane
Castle who was experimented on by
vilgafort and brainwashed or mind
controlled into thinking she was Siri a
union between Siri and the emperor
strengthens his claim to the throne in
sintra and makes his takeover of the
north easier with several armies with
allegiances disintra now having to fight
alongside nilfgaard in a quick scene
between Jennifer and crotch on crate I
hope I'm pronouncing that right he
explains that if Siri joins nilfgaard he
and the people of skelegat due to their
allegiance will have to follow suit if
Siri is siding with nilfgaard
we're obliged to join at the same time
Fran Jill and Francesca make their own
play frangelo wants to be Imperial
governor of zintria and Francesca free
to lead her people but the emperor still
needs her Army of scoyatel to fight in
the north and she is basically forced to
agree now frangila wants to get the hell
out of nilfgaard remember she was
imprisoned and forced to drink wine to
see if it had poison in it but she won't
exactly be welcomed by the north for her
prior Allegiance with the emperor so she
devises a plan to kidnap Siri at the
ceremony but Francesca has given in to
her fate and doesn't want to risk losing
what she's already got that's when
frangila drops the bomb that it was the
emperor that had her baby killed the
baby she thought was killed by rodania
understandably Francesca is pissed that
frangila had been keeping this news from
her so it'll be interesting to see how
these two plan on leaving nilfgaard and
if they'll devise a plan to take down
the emperor there's also the interesting
aspect that Francesca knows what the
real Siri looks like she she saw her at
the Battle of sherawat this vital piece
of information could create new
directions the story could go when she
sees that this Siri on the throne is an
imposter and just a reminder before we
continue if you like these types of
videos be sure to like And subscribe
every little bit helps the channel out
geralt's Arc this season is all about
making a choice up until this point
geralt as well as many of the witchers
have adopted a neutral stance in the
Affairs of others in episode 5 both
vilgafort's and dixtra try to sway him
to their side but he refuses the
physical manifestation of this is
renfrey's Cloak Broach from season one
something he keeps attached to the hilt
of his sword as a reminder not to become
involved in conflicts between humans the
last time he got involved was when he
stood in the way of renfrey's quest to
murder stregabore which ended in geralt
killing her so at the end of the season
when Garrett lets go of this brooch and
kills a bunch of nifguardian soldiers
it's a metaphor for him letting go of
his neutrality he'll take any side as
long as it means protecting Siri he's
real lies that remaining neutral is
futile as Destiny always finds a way
I've always tried to stay above The Fray
and life always finds a way to force my
hand after her journey through the
desert Siri finds herself captured by a
slaver known as scomil and is taken to
the town of gliswin to the west of the
Korat desert there she meets a fellow
captive by the name of Kaylee who is a
member of a group of nerda Wells known
as the rats this group comes to their
aid and among them is missile the same
girl who we met in episode 3 this season
who stole serious money now series given
the opportunity to kill her captor and
this is both her first human kill if you
don't count when she was under the
effects of volathmir and marks her
transition to falca the same name of the
woman she received Visions from in the
desert falca was a fire Mage who like
Siri was a girl forgotten by her family
trying to recover her throne but falca
was a ruthless woman who murdered her
own father and started a rebellion she'd
do whatever she needed to to get what
she wanted this gave her their
reputation nation of being a cursed
Elven demon in a grim warning falca
tells Siri that those she loves will
betray her and to them she's nothing but
a pawn and at the end of the episode
when the rats ask her what her name is
she responds falca implying that she may
be going down the same ruthless path
that the original falca trod it's also
smart for her to use an alias since the
entire continent is looking for her with
Siri still on the Run we see yennefer
writing a letter to geralt that her
Mission next season is to create a quote
safe world for Siri to return to while
geralt heads to nilfgaard alongside
yaskir and milva in his quest to find
Siri but this still leaves us with a big
question mark on how the show is going
to transition from Henry Cavill playing
geralt to Liam Hemsworth The Producers
have already said this change will be
quote very meta meaning something that
is abstract or can be analyzed at a
higher level beyond the subject matter
of the show itself so we won't be seeing
anything kind of superficial like
multiple dimensions or magic to explain
this change knowing how geralt changed
from a man of neutrality to one of
choosing sides fits this meta
understanding my guess is that when
season 4 Begins the story will take
right off with Liam who will still be
playing geralt but now as a geralt who
has done away with this code of
neutrality the old geralt is dead on
with the new as showrunner Lauren
Schmidt hisridge told Entertainment
Weekly quote geralt has a new mission in
mind when we come back to him in season
four he's a slightly different geralt
than we expected end quote this mission
is to find Siri neutrality be damned but
what do you think of this change is it a
cop-out or a fitting way to change the
character let me know what you think and
what you thought about the season in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
[__]